hello there
it's update day in fortnight which means
it's time to look over all the map
changes
and tiny pieces of information which
build up the law around the story
if you'd like to support my nonsense
please slap code adamarrow in the store
but a like on this video would be just
as appreciated
anyway sit your butt down for five
minutes and let's go through what's new
in week three of chapter two
season six
the update we have to begin with because
it lets me bring back
the sacred sounds of hot watch at the
start of the season up in the hills
around lazy lake we found a sheriff
looking for a new home back then it was
barely a campsite
but look what happened this week the
sheriff is officially calling this spot
home and i think it's time to bring this
back
hot watch sheriff edition right now the
basic outline is in place but pallets
decor and exposed walls tell us this is
going to take some time to finish
so we'll leave him now to get back to
work and we'll come back in another
fortnight
fortnight i haven't said this for a
while hot watch forever
[Music]
okay on to the real big part of the
update the dinosaurs
let's be honest if someone told you back
in 2018 that dinos would come to
fortnite
what would you have thought there's a
diplodocus
i tried to tame one by the way and uh
yeah it went well
the thing which i adore was the build up
to these guys arriving
two weeks ago we spotted the eggs and
watched them five days later they began
to hatch
and so i set up camp and just stared at
them constantly
the brilliant touch by epic was the
sound added the micro heart beat inside
the egg
which grew stronger as the days passed
[Music]
then yesterday the eggs were cracked
from top to toe
and to finish this cycle here they are
now just like the chickens the wolves
and the bars
there is a few different variations of
these dinosaurs in their colour scheme
but the thing we all want to know can a
raptor defeat a pack of wolves
well well no but it tried very hard it
was actually stuck on a bush
i guess we now know the weakness of
fortnite dinosaurs trees
vegans rejoice by the way if you have
any dumb dinosaur myths for me and my
discord to test
please throw them my way in the comments
next update over at pleasant park the
map has seen a very peculiar update
the calm streets of pleasant have been
altered by a wall being erected on the
outskirts
let's call this donald wall no no reason
why
the wall is exactly at the spot where
the modern mechanical world meets the
primal world
both sides are outlining their territory
could this be the first steps of war
between the two time periods
the only thing we can do right now is
wait and see we'll likely learn more via
a challenge
in-game in fact before we move on take a
look at pleasant when gliding into a
match
there's a visual glitch which wasn't
here last week which
potentially shows pleasant park could be
changing into a primal zone in future
updates
the vibrant orange outline must
represent something
or maybe it's just another visual glitch
and means absolutely nothing
either way i thought you should know
let's move on a micro change a bunch of
you guys told me about is down at
slurpee swamp
last week the water line receded huge
veins of bedrock appeared
and it looked for a few days as if this
place was drying out
well this week everything is back to
normal no need to panic
slurp levels have returned this could be
linked to batman's entrance in a few
updates time
as in the background of the cover image
is an explosion
down in the slurpy swamps i'll keep you
updated
and also see if you can spot any batman
related items around the map
in the comic book he builds his own
primal batcave
i hope that comes to the game
[Music]
over at the central spire where the
foundation hibernates good old rock the
dwayne johnson
i expected to see change but i don't
think there is
i'll put a side by side on screen now of
the zero point
would you say it's changed at all or are
they the same i'm not certain maybe it's
a little more angry this week
around the spire are these pink crystals
which again they are related to
challenges later in the week
but this is interesting the corruption
seems to be seeping through again
so maybe the foundation is struggling a
little bit in that orb
the island has grown wild and so
due to core challenges in fortnite i've
decided to add a new section to this
update video
we're going to call this the law a place
where we can keep an eye on all the
updates
each week which link back to the story
depending on the tier you are this week
you'll unlock the epic styles foterana
raz and the spire assassins the chrome
version is cool and all
but check out the runic versions we can
clearly see
it's not only raz who has room tattoos
and markings
tirana does too tehran tirana
tirana how do you say it and the last
time we saw these markings was on kevin
the cube
the core mission this week has us
finding toilet seats with the image of
jonesy upon them
and returning them to tehrana in bony
burbs she then sends us to talk to raz
at the old coliseum
and nearby we have an audio file to
listen to get this in your ear holes
have a listen
[Applause]
does he say listen to crystal saw the
crystal song
i can't make it out i need help the only
crystal song i know
is from teen titans and it's not like
there's a fortnight crossover with teen
titans is there
oh raven oh this quest line continues
but i haven't finished it yet so let's
put a pin in this for now
and we'll bring it back next time we
meet up i think kevin the cube is coming
back
as do many of you guys and the questline
we're going through now
is the beginning of something epic
so there we have it in terms of updates
i think that's week three covered
did i miss anything small or big please
let me know and i'll add it to the next
episode
i'm adam from playstation grenade thanks
for watching and an extra thanks to
these guys for rocking code adamaru last
week
thank you very much it does make a huge
difference okay i'll stop wasting your
time
it's been a pleasure see ya